it's monday the 24th of january we're
back [__]
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
draftkings i don't know if you watched
the nfl this weekend but there's four
teams remaining that's it there's four
teams left for you to bet on draft king
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the nfl gotten down
to super bowl 56 new customers get 56
to one odds on any team bet five dollars
and get 2
and 80 and free bets if your team wins
not a new customer draftking still has
your back you can experience the
conference championships with the same
game parlays and hopefully get a profit
boost that's what draftkings is known
for combine multiple bets from the same
game for bigger payout the more legs you
add the more money you can win how do
you like that from your uncle
[__] joey so do me a favor
draftkings is safe secure and reliable
and you can with deposit and withdraw
cash whenever the [__] you want it
starts by you though download the
draftking sports book app now today use
promo code joey j o e y and get 56
to one odds on any nfl team just spend
five dollars and win
280 and free bets if your team wins
that's promo code joey at the official
sports betting partner of the nfl you
got to be 21 older new jersey indiana or
pa only new cap customers only minimum 5
deposit and dollar wager required one
per customer restrictions
do apply see draftkings
slash sports book for details now if you
got a gaming problem
call 1-800 gambler or get the help that
you need brother but if not let's get
this party started the road to the super
bowl starts with draftkings today code
joey
[Music]
sorry about that i got a pubic hair from
the 80s the joint is also brought to you
by
liquid iv the last of the eggnog is gone
the champagne is flat and it's time to
get back to work i want to see nothing
but [__] and elbows and nothing
helps you bounce back faster
than liquid iv let me tell you something
they've been a sponsor for like three
months i started drinking this when i
got colvin in january and i'm [__]
sold tremendous whether you're drinking
the cherry the acai berry or the grape
tremendous one stick of liquid iv and 16
ounces of water will hydrate you faster
than water alone i'm even doing a
package at night because the sleep apnea
machine dehydrates me so i keep it next
to him and i drink it all night i'm
waking up a lot more refreshed it's made
with premium ingredients like it's vegan
non-gmo and gluten dairy and soy free
and their support and frontline workers
over 19 million servings donated so far
listen liquid iv is tremendous you heard
it from uncle joey the grape
unbelievable after you work out if you
sweat a lot you go to jiu jitsu liquid
iv is for you
grab liquid iv in bulk nationwide at
costco or i'm going to give you 25 off
when you go to liquid iv.com
use promo code joey again liquidive.com
use promo code joey i'm going to give
you 25 off anything when you use promo
code joey at
liquidity.com experience better
hydration with liquid iv.com
i love you savages let's get this party
started jack
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 24th of january we're
almost there i missed you little [__]
i didn't see you all last week we had a
calvordial situation here on the joint
uncle joey's joint so we're sorry about
wednesday we were able to put up monday
morning wednesday i had a lot of people
hitting me where's the [__] podcast
hey listen [__]
did you not see the [__] memo
on monday that we put out we got a
cavorio situation we're putting the
podcast up a little later but late
people still need that podcast so
we're [__] back [__] feeling
good looking good
i'm
i'm three weeks away from being 59
i'm not excited about that [__] age
especially all these comics punching the
[__] ticket my heart goes out to
louis anderson his family my man scott
day
who was a good friend of louis he used
to be the talent coordinator at the
comedy store when i got there my heart
goes out to those guys and my heart goes
out
to bob saget and his family i know i
didn't post any pictures of me hugging
with both of them and jumping up and
down and
you know crying on a video telling you
how much
they meant to me or even writing a song
i thought about writing a song for louie
anderson but you know give me a [__]
break people
they were both great [__] i didn't
even think about me loaf i didn't give a
[__]
meatloaf i'm not even thinking about you
you know what i'm saying
i like paradise by the dashboard light
but once i looked at you i moved on back
to robert plan i wasn't a big [__]
fan of meatloaf but at least i'm being
honest with you guys that's what's
lacking today that nobody came out and
said you know what betty white could
suck my dick she was about to turn 100
anyway what's the big [__] deal like
people like betty white does what do you
think our next
train step was what would you think she
was headed at last i checked when she
hit 65 you're going any [__] day so
if she made it to 99 light a candle have
a drink for betty white watch the
[__] golden girls i don't know what
to tell you people die do you understand
me we die
we're gonna die whether you're [__]
brad pitt or whether you're [__]
obama everybody's gotta punch the ticket
at one day or another so you know betty
white died isn't that a shame not for
nothing she was 99 she had one foot in
the grave and the other one in a banana
peel for [__] real so you know i
loved her she made me giggle when i was
a kid but you know people want you to do
these big [__] memorials for people
when they die now uh when do you find
time to do this [__] memorial when
did you find time to write a song for
bob's haggard i never
have you heard this song i don't know
what to tell you
i don't even know what to tell you you
know i'm saying i don't know i'm not
quite listen to each his own everybody
wants to be a composer me i just want to
[__] come on here twice a week
[__] with you savages tell you the
truth about what i'm feeling and how i'm
doing and that's it i mean what the [__]
you want from me i'm running out listen
if you think i want to come on here
every monday and wednesday and tell you
another story guess again go gone
sicklers podcasting i got plenty of
stories on there you know even though a
good story on a monday it's not a bad
[__] idea but guys i'm not gonna you
know i'm trying to search for [__] to
tell you
i don't have the life i did i'm not
going through airports shoplifting water
no more sitting next to fat people
farting on planes
i [__] took a big chunk i don't even
go to a weed store anymore that was part
of my day i love going over whether i
had two pounds of weed at the house or a
[__] seed i went to the weed store
that's what you do you mingle hi how are
you good to see you oh you have any
vitamin 2 water oh see
remember when they had the cbd water i
was drinking that [__] to like blood out
of the [__] ass that cbd in that
water [__] me up but i went to the
weed store every day at least you see
some people up there hi
i want something that
gets me high but not really
i don't feel like eating apples
afterwards i mean
and you see i love that [__] in
california there was two specific weed
stores that i would go to just to
torture people like and just to see
people torturing these poor [__]
young kids
and asking them a bunch of questions
then they want to give you a dollar tip
listen and i would listen i would tell
the [__] clock clerks listen tell
these [__] people to go [__]
themselves they come in here i i don't
really want to smoke marijuana but my my
son said i should try a vapor
you know
my son says i should try a vapor but i
don't want it to make me hungry and i'm
like whoa
you're at the wrong place okay go up the
corner to the insane asylum maybe they
got something for you over here when you
come in here it's to get high tuck
sucker i want my eyes to be red you
understand me i want to eat doritos why
the [__] do you get high for to do what
to drink wine with your [__] [__]
friends go [__] yourself i drink wine to
get munchies to giggle listen to [__]
music you know i got a tremendous
album of the week this week for you
patreon [__] we're turning it
up
we're switching it up with i got new
music for you even music what am i gonna
talk to you about music for i don't know
about music i follow any trunk he takes
pictures have you ever seen follow eddie
trunk
follow eddie trunk and look at the guys
he goes on like and he does uh those
festivals every week and [__] have you
seen that [__] and i gotta tell you man
all these festivals they got to happen
in florida
because i've never seen ugly people like
that in all my [__] life and i've
been to monaca new jersey
i don't know where the [__] they do
these tours that you know eddie tapes
him from the back i love eddie of that
he's a music [__] god i love him with
all my heart but when i see him post
those pictures with these old geezers
and they're out there and they got the
long hair and you're like wow
oh my god this is not good
and people in the audience are my
[__] age
with like docking t-shirts on jumping up
and down and listen god bless
god bless him you know i'm saying i know
you work for amazon all week
and this is the big [__] deal at the
end of the week but there's got to be
something better there's got to be
something better i can't do it i can't
go to one of those concerts when i go to
a concert i want to see young people i
want to i want to be inspired i want
them to bring me life i don't want to
see guys that are up there talking about
uh
you know we can't drink no more because
my listen i can't listen to that [__] no
more at all at all i like my little
records
you know i sit here i smoke some dope at
night i come out i was telling mike
you know when you get covered you lose
your mind that listen
people talk about the covet you know why
people die
i'll tell you why people die because
you're by yourself for [__] five
[__] days that's why you die you can
be like
this is as boring as can [__] be
this uh what they call this [__] i gotta
go equal like whatever the [__] it is
you gotta go hide by yourself
hi but no the other one when you [__]
go and uh you know what they tell you
you have to you have to do whatever
quarantine quarantine means debt
quarantine you could just jerk off so
many times you know what i'm saying plus
plus you got a headache so if you lay
your head the one way and you bang a
lefty you're all done you know there's
nothing to [__] do doing quarantine
like they should just have like a county
jail like if you get a covert come on
down
come on down there's plenty of things
you can play [__] you know so
everybody's got covered in there so you
got like 20 people covered your immune
system will get stronger and you're in
there playing shuffleboard with other
people breathing on their neck blackjack
right or wrong a casino for covet people
i'm gonna work on it right [__] it now
and you heard it here i'm gonna call
pete davidson and go pete that little
boat you got to
going back from brooklyn to [__]
staten island i got even a better scam
people were covered that's it everybody
in there were [__] those b helmets on
and you come in you gamble you know i'm
saying if you get a little heart attack
because it is so [__] boring to
quarantine
between the books the tv that listen
television
is that an all-time [__] horror show
it really is i don't know if you people
watch tv
listen i have friends that tell me the
shows they watch
and i want to stab them to get them out
of their [__] misery because you
don't sit there with some fat chick
every night and watch that [__]
i can't [__] do it no more i don't
know what you [__] are watching
football's got me for about like
football's almost over
great games this weekend [__] uh
the inter victim backfired on [__]
the guy from green bay everybody's
hating on joe rogan right now because
the guy from green bay rogers [__]
tank listen as soon as they lost i was
like that ain't the victim backfire and
i'm having rides and [__]
uh great [__] games you know i don't
even know who else played i didn't watch
the ufc card i'm not paying 75 bucks to
see two black guys beat each other up i
already did that i could do that for
three dollars just put a black lives
matter [__] rally on and you can see
black people throwing fists flying
through the [__] hand i'm not paying
the big 75. i wanted to watch moreno
against the other guy and i actually put
a bet on [__] uh
mcgovernoff's brother uh you know the
[__] uh whatever
i forget with his name
i i don't know guys this is what happens
when you smoke weed again okay you stop
remembering the megabill off whatever
khabib's brother that's what i'm trying
to [__] say khabib's brother that i
didn't even want dog i didn't even see
the [__] prelims
i went to i was supposed to go to dinner
with my brother saturday night right and
we're supposed to go to some place in
south amboy i don't know
[__] sayerville me my brother my wife
my daughter [__] steakhouse is the
best [__] steak around 58
and what are you going to do
if you go to [__] supermarket they
want 24 for a steak i might as well have
a mexican marinated throw in the oven
and
get me a [__] baked potato with it so
i don't know saturday i woke up i wasn't
feeling too good
my daughter wasn't feeling good we went
to eat something and her stomach hurts
so we just came home and chilled out and
i had to do [__] around the house
obviously i went to the gym i [__]
walk by the way whoever referred to
walking to me lisa
i'm [__] loving it
and listen it was rough for about two
weeks but forget about it like i told
you [__] you throw on some
music and you take two little [__]
hits off that
freeze pipe bubbler
you'll be walking the [__] saigon and
back i'm loving it i'm walking like
double of what i was walking just by
putting on [__] music am i losing
weight no but i'm getting stronger i
feel good you know what i'm saying i go
out it's been cold
the sun comes out listen i put the
hooded sweatshirt on like i did today
you go outside get a little vitamin d it
ain't that cold that you can't it's like
30 something degrees that you can't go
outside and get a little sun we're
supposed to get snow again this week
twice whatever hey people like we're
getting snow it's [__] january that's
what it's supposed to do it's supposed
to be cold
january and [__] february why are you
surprised but anyway what are we talking
about here
uh last week what i did miss talking to
you guys about was i missed the
anniversary
it was my
39th anniversary maybe 41 who's counting
you know i'm saying
41.39 it's all the same it's not even on
the [__] computers no more from my
first arrest last week and
you know
sometimes i get high at night because i
got to do the uh i gotta [__] uh
do an outline for erica to write the
book you know we're oh my god we're
almost out of this [__] we're on
we're on to 2007 [__] team
the last four years and how i felt and
what i was going through pretty [__]
interesting you know how we put this
book together eric and i now it's close
to the end there was nothing really
happening in my career we're about to
shoot the netflix special
we're about to do the sopranos and uh
just personal [__] was going on with
mercy
and my wife they were getting sick of
california that's pretty much that's the
rest of the [__] book and what i've
learned to wrap up
boom [__] go over the beginning again
have that [__] in by march 2022
we spoke to my agent to talk to the book
publishing maybe you know they want to
put it out in may 2023 i can't wait and
neither can you we can't wait for this
[__] we got to get this out november of
2022 that's what i was [__] hoping
but
who knows like we'll find out and i'll
keep you
[__] posted
so like i was saying the beginning
listen for you people who asked
i met louie and saggit
at the store
you know
when i met bob sagan
i was [__] blown away if you want to
know that i saw him up at the front bar
and i walked out there this had to be in
98 and we had a little chit chat
and maybe a few weeks after that i met
louie anderson mitchy shaw introduced
him to me uh [__] sweetheart you know
i didn't know what to expect from listen
when i moved to l.a
for you people want to know like you
know how do you treat celebrities or
what do you do
when i move to l.a i assume two things i
assumed one
i was gonna at the comedy store
especially
i was gonna meet a lot of celebrities i
mean my first night in the comedy store
as an open miker i saw
the guy from
the last dragon
the star of that movie was at the comedy
store
lou gossett
the guy that won the academy award for
[__] uh office and a gentleman
the first night i walked in the comedy
store was like
january 28
1997 we're going up on an anniversary
this week i think friday will be uh
yeah [__]
since i moved from seattle to l.a we
left i don't know
around this time
we did yeah we left
seattle on a sunday night
it could be the anniversary right now no
no no no because we left like 10 days
before
we left seattle we had a [__] dog
an rv and a car following the [__] rv
you know we had it on a hitch
and when we got to san francisco the
[__] frame broke on the rv like the
[__] the tires i swear to god there
was a flat and when they went to pick up
the rv to tow it
the back [__] axle just fell off and
was going in a different direction
tremendous i just held my head when [__]
like that happens you're like you know
what what are you gonna do it looks like
i'm staying i'm staying in san francisco
for a week and that's what happened we
ended up staying in san francisco i
performed every night at rooster t
feathers i went to a different place
every night and did a guest set that's
what i did back then i went out at night
and then uh
we drove into la on a [__] monday we
got into la maybe seven
o'clock at night we took showers in the
[__] rv like animals
we went to acapulco
you know people were telling me as soon
as you go to l.a call me out and i was
like [__] you
i got one destination [__] and
that's the comedy store for the open mic
and i [__] went down there and wheels
was there eddie griffin was there
just these are the people i remember
from the first night man i was like [__]
i gotta be in here and i remember i
asked
don barris
if i could go up and don put me up
and i ate a bag of dog [__] but it
didn't matter to me because
you know i was going up there that was
gonna go on my resume the first thing i
did when i got home i was putting
[__] the comedy store on my resume
and uh
i was prepared to like if i saw those
guys on the first [__] night and
there was just an open mic who was i
going to see in the future so i prepared
for that but i also
did something that a lot of people don't
do even in 98 in 97 i was like listen
one thing i am gonna do is i'm not
talking to these [__]
like i'm not talking to these big time
comics unless they talk to me
and that's how i really handled that
situation so if you're a young comic or
whatever you know what you want to get
to a comic don't go up to him and tell
him he's your favorite comic and blah
blah blah
go on the stage
when you know that he's watching you and
blow it the [__] up
trust me i see any comic blow up a
[__] stage on any level at any room i
was in you ask around
i would go up to a comic because that
was a very funny [__]
set you know you you know a little
encouragement never [__] killed
anybody
you know sometime now in today's world i
used to always
go up to a woman and go hey man that was
a great set that you're very funny
whatever now it's a different era you
can't do that
but uh there was a time you know tammy
pascatelli was here this weekend she was
performing at uncle vinnie's down in
point pleasant i saw she was coming to
town
and i called like wednesday night i go
hey i don't know if you got a hotel yet
i have an extra room here my wife you
know we know my wife knows tammy from
the comedy store we were all there in 98
99 busting our [__] humps
even longer tammy was there for a few
years after i mean yeah she was tight
with mitzy you know tammy was one of the
guys you know me her rogan i still
remember us going to [__] eat at a
pink dot after our shows just 10 of us
would walk the pink dot it was a great
time hari duncan you know
so
i called it wednesday night i go tammy i
know you're coming to town if you don't
need to get a hotel you know you might
as well save 200 300 bucks just stay
here we got plenty of [__] room she
was like no i'm staying at my
sister-in-law's but i love that you
reached out and i love to see you
so you know what man i was thinking
about saturdays in a hotel room
i don't know what you [__] think a
comic does on a saturday in a hotel room
you know for me at first i was i would
always be hungover from night before you
know and i would get up eat and then go
on search for the coke for that night
that's when i was a feature act and i
was on the road and i was opening for
rogue and i didn't give a [__] about my
career but once you become a headliner
you know you take your days you know
your days a little bit more seriously
but there's no other way to say this
those saturdays in the hotel room it
[__] sucks
especially when you're in a comedy club
because
you're in that room you got that
thursday night
friday you maybe went to the gym maybe
went to lunch maybe did a little radios
or at least you did something
friday night you go back to your hotel
room saturday there's no radio there's
not much of [__] anything
if you're a headliner you get up maybe
eat breakfast at the hotel maybe go
somewhere for breakfast to get out and
walk around maybe do a little workout at
the gym i always
talk i was i looked at my bag
about two months ago i had to go in
there to see if i had rolling papers one
night i got wrong papers in my bag and i
had them in my bag
i was prepared for everything when i was
on the road like everything
my suitcase had
eye buds in it [__] back up sleep
apnea mass [__]
rolling papers i had vitamins on the
road band-aids
[__] if you cut yourself shaving that
stick you [__] paint yourself with i
had that [__] on the road nail clippers
there was a bag in my suitcase
that had everything in that [__]
so i would be prepared
if i went on the road you know backup
computer stuff backup charges
you know
aspirins i had some i went through it
i'm like wow
i really had this down when i [__]
you know when i was traveling i had it
down to a [__] science i mean things
happen that you don't have uh
control over but i always brought swim
trunks with me just in case the hotel
had a heated pool or a steam bag i was
always one step ahead of that
[__] and that's what you know 30
[__] years joey you're prepared and i
didn't listen by no way that i [__]
write the book i copied it from doug
stano
i saw doug's [__] travel car when i
before i got into comedy he stayed at my
house in boulder
maybe
92 he stayed as a feature act
and then he came back like two years
later as a headliner and he stayed at my
house and i remember walking down
through his car with him
and looking at this car going wow
wow
this guy had everything in his [__]
car books
a suit a steam bat you know everything
was in that trunk [__] neatly put in
there and that's you know you got to be
efficient when you're on the road and
when i had my [__] road car forget it
i did the same thing frisbees
basketballs footballs a skateboard have
you ever seen me in a skateboard no but
you might as well bring one you don't
know what you're going to meet on the
[__] road i had everything in that
[__] trunk and i was [__] prepared
so
what i'm saying is on saturdays a comic
just gets bored so i said do you want to
come over
and eat so we hooked up uh my daughter
had a play date so we took care of that
and then she came over
and me my wife and tammy just went and
got a bite to eat and just talked about
old times and
you know just talked about what was
going on and how the store was back then
and she brought it up we were talking
about all the people that
it was really different like i still
remember having conversations with
he's he passed away not
not uh
he used to have a show on hbo
and he used to date sarah superman i
forget what the [__] great guy gary
shandling
like gary shandling i'm being a [__]
in jail and watching the gary shanley
show on hbo i remember i still remember
being in boulder county [__] jail
waiting to get bailed out and on a
thursday night if you because in boulder
county jail back then
back then in 1987 baldi county jail was
a [__] paradise listen
people in boulder county jail got
arrested
to go to boulder county jail
if you were tapped out you were having
some problems at home with your parents
and [__] like that
you went out you broke a window you
called somebody a [__] or a racial
slur and they give you 60 days in
boulder county i saw those guys
they would walk in there like they were
going to the [__]
playmate playboy mansion
because they knew they were going to get
cigarettes
you got free cigarettes
at boulder county jail i'm not talking
about marlboro marlboro lights they gave
you a bugler
and they gave you you get hey listen
when things are bad bugler works how do
i know because i smoked that [__] inside
a couple times with a bun with a little
piece of [__] they would put a hash
in it in boulder you take two hits by
the kitchen whoo
that bugle gets you [__] up and it
gives you bad [__] breath and your
teeth decay quickly you understand me
i'm not a dentist i'm not [__] you
know but
i used to hit that [__] bugler they
gave you packs of bugler and i would get
the bugle and trade it for [__]
kool-aid you know uncle joey dog i had
the [__] bugler combination and the
milk a lot of bodybuilders in there
county jail and they want their milk to
make protein shakes i swear to god
[__] hilarious
so
uh
plus
boulder county jail back then
had carpeting
on the floors and [__]
in the general population areas like if
you boulder county jail wouldn't
classify you like sticky fingered
[__] no
they classified you
like how long you were in there and how
your behavior was
so first i don't know what they called
an indoctrination
you were up till nine and then if you
made it out of there you went to a
different color and you were up till ten
then if you made it out of there you
were like in [__] red you made it to
and then the next [__] step of the
game if you made it up there you up to
like one and they had cable tv
so your goal
in bold account you think i'm [__]
kidding you i remember when i got into
comedy in 92
91 i was hosting at the broker and there
was a [__] article on the front page
of the boulder broker at that time the
boulder broke was the club i worked at
the
whatever the [__] the name of the
newspaper was in boulder you know a lot
of newspapers in my life
but in the front page they said that
colorado's had two jails
weren't that were in the top five jails
in the country
like they did like a [__]
intermediate survey in jail and
everybody wanted to go to aspen number
one and boulder was number two that's
the way it was for you because ask him
didn't really have a jail
sorry to interrupt my intriguing
conversation on a monday but listen
we're sponsored by better help online
therapy listen it's just like going to
the gym of the dentist we should be
caring for our mental health as much as
our physical health me i've been with
better health for about seven months now
and they've helped me through what i was
going through whatever it was it was in
my mind my anxiety is at bay and i'm way
better so do me a favor better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist but if you
don't want to see the camera you don't
have to it's much more affordable a lot
more affordable than in person therapy
and you can start communicating with
your therapist in less than 48 hours
give it a try
see why two million people have used
better help online therapy including
your including your uncle joey was
sponsored
by better help
and joint listeners get 10 percent off
their first month at
betterhelp.com diaz d-i-a-z
that's betterhelp.com
slash diaz
better help
b-e-t-t-e-r h-e-l-p dot com
slash diaz and check out better helps
new podcast getting better on apple
spotify and everywhere else you get your
podcast back to the podcast savage's
jail
aspen threw you in like some [__]
county place that's with ted bundy
listen ted bundy escaped from there
and that was still the jail they had in
1992.
the same jail was like a [__] cell in
aspen county courthouse they don't have
a [__] jail or a county jail i think
you got to go all the way to glenwood
springs but if you get arrested in aspen
they're nice people in colorado they
don't want you to go to county jail so
they keep you in [__] aspen and they
would bring you in catering
from all the restaurants in the area who
wouldn't want to do that you're up there
eating [__] french food
you know tibetan food whatever the [__]
they got in asking because people eat
all that crazy [__]
[Music]
sorry about that cough i'm still getting
flashbacks of the coven and the weed
don't help but who gives a [__] i got
one for the great one a banana peel just
like betty white when you're a comic now
you got to be sweating if you're [__]
old after betty what happened not well
betty white wasn't a stand-up from the
store but after bob sagan and [__] uh
uh my man over there you got to be
saying to yourself who the [__] is next
so that's how i've been feeling lately
that's why i've been taking a [__]
multivitamin a new one i'm drinking some
purple [__] from my [__] joints so it
don't hurt as much but anyway we were
talking about this uh
comedy store thing with tammy and who
was up there guys there used to be a lot
of older guys when i got up there for
about
four years we had alan stephens we had
i'd see lenny clark come in from time to
time another one of my [__] idols you
had charlie hill the indian dude you had
bob saget you had
you know louie anderson would come in
and visit mitzi you know on saturday
nights admits he was there
all these tremendous comics would come
down some that you heard of
and some that you've never heard of that
you know i just calmly have moved them
there was a lot of guys that came to the
store back then on saturday nights
that had moved on to producing
writing yeah you had your saggits and
you had your
i can't even gary shamblings you had
your andrew dice clays
you had your judy golds she had a lot of
older names that were coming and i got
to tell you man
i never had a beef with no leo i stayed
away from them
for as long as i could i never got in
the way of gary shandling i never spoke
up there until i was spoken to
so once they started talking to me you
know it's not like gary shandling was
down there
every [__] night
it's not like
bob saget was down there every [__]
night it's not like louie anderson was
down every night when i first met louie
he still had his he would only come in
like during the week because he had his
uh show out in vegas and it was doing
great and louie would come to the store
to actually take talent from the store
to use them as openers i'll never forget
that and i'll never forget having a
conversation
on why he couldn't use me
and guys i did nine years on the [__]
church
i did two years a year or two with
felicia
and we got two years on this you've
never heard me say the conversation
louis and i had on why i couldn't work
from
he came to me as a man he goes hey man
you're a funny dude and [__] i would
love to use you on my show
but i do an all
family show
i do a lot of old ages a lot of all ages
show where any age could come and people
bring in their 13 year old grandson to
see me and louie i learned one thing
from louie man in fact i went to see
louie when i was on vegas working that
that catcherizing star i used to work at
the [__] hotel with the swords and
[__]
and i remember one night i had an earl i
was a feature act i wasn't headlining
yet so i got out of there and caught
louie zach and i i'll never forget one
thing
louis did on stage
louie before he went on stage
he would find out who had a birthday
and he would go in his [__] pocket
not the hotel not the casino not anybody
else
louie would go in his pocket and buy
roses
for any woman that was coming to the
show
and i remember that i watched the whole
show and he was [__] funny as [__]
and i remembered that he came out i
don't know if anybody else did this a
lot of you guys are going to listen to
this and go joey what the [__] we've
been to vegas shows before it has been i
don't know i saw louie do it first and
that's why it inspired me so much
and i got what louie did
he gave them roses not like he called
them up to the stage he walked this
chubby little ass out to him
and said this is for you for coming and
let me tell you something the night i
went there was maybe
six women he gave roses to
i think five of them just broke out into
tears they were like grandmas and older
moms that their husbands had surprised
them with louie or whatever and i'll
never forget how i felt about that like
i'm like that could be my [__] mother
and louie is going out of his way
to give that mom flowers to make her
vegas weekend complete whatever it cost
him 50 for the dozen 60 for the dozen
that's 300 and yes joey he was making
20 000 a night but just that
anybody could send somebody to get you
roses
and to [__] give them to you in the
hallway no
louie stopped his [__] show
and walked out there with the roses and
was like here thank you for coming to my
show he would shake the husband's hand
then he would have the whole place give
her a [__] applaud
jesus my heart sank i remember going up
to louie afterwards going bro it was a
great show
but you [__] destroyed these women
like you [__] they'll never forget
this they're going to go you know it's
like a chubby chick going well [__]
what's it do for [__]
was the dude that was in vacation that's
been a [__] celebrity in vegas
for like 80 000 years he was like a
vegas look-alike
i don't even know he still i don't know
he was like in vegas
family vacation and whenever they went
to las vegas that time
wayne newton
wayne knew him
like wayne newton if you ever get onto a
wayne newton show listen
i'm not a fan of [__] wayne newton's
if you want me to sit here and go i love
wayne newton no he looked like the
[__] model for mad magazine i don't
know i i don't know how that wasn't a
big
but i'm a fan of [__] performers
so i caught what's his name
years ago in fact i caught him when i
worked for [__] the sports advisors
with stu finer i'll never forget that
somebody had tickets for every night
they had tickets for different [__]
circus de soleil
that's who i went to [__] circus
diesel with i went with the sport guys
and they told me not to [__]
get high or nothing and i got super high
when i was sitting
in uh whatever de chalet whatever the
[__] it is some guy came up to me tapped
me in the show and they go put your
hands up like why you robbed me and they
go no no put your hands up when they got
on my [__] hands and i had to push
them up while they held and i was i was
[__] sweating that they were gonna
fall backwards and break their neck
but yeah i always went whenever i went
to vegas i always caught those type of
shows just to learn
if you're going to be a performer you
got to [__] learn you know sometimes
i went to one night we were doing
connecticut and me and rogan a bunch of
us shot over and caught donna summer and
she was christian by then she wasn't
singing like you know love to love your
baby and all that [__] but what i'm
saying was like what i took from louie
was
how he talked to the women after the
show and how he made people feel
so when i saw him a few weeks later i'm
like listen
you're gonna have to give them [__]
roses
and you know like a free pass i get why
i can't open for you
and we were tight friends after that
what do you mean by tight joey
whenever i saw him at the store we'd
discuss comedy how he was doing
i remember he wanted a diet and got
healthy i saw him while he was uh
doing the zac californica show and he
was telling me that he was working out
and blah blah blah
and he was really trying so yeah i'm
gonna miss louie louie uh
told me a few things about comedy
that were interesting the same way
andrew's done
the same way bob saget has done you know
bob
[Music]
again i didn't know bob
like the way i know joe i didn't know
bob the way i know duncan
i didn't know bob the way i know ari but
i knew bob bob would come into the store
we'd [__] a little bit
you know i met bob in 98 i asked him for
advice on being dirty and guess what he
gave me the best advice in the world
which is keep pushing them and keep
aggravating them and keep being dirty
don't change
for a tv show because they're not going
to change for you
so i took bob saget's advice to heart
and i was like wow
so again i wasn't
i don't even have i don't even know if i
got a picture of bob saget
i don't even know if i got a picture
with louis anderson if i look i might
have like a [__] couple of us doing
like a tuesday night or a benefit up at
the store like from 2003 or one or
something
but even if i had those pictures i
wasn't gonna show it up everybody's
doing that i decided to do something
different i wanted to think about what
my relationship was with them
and bring it to you guys here and that's
it we move the [__] on i'm not gonna sit
here
and uh you know it's just
it's just getting weird out there guys
and i don't know
i was telling mike that
uh
you know they they last week the podcast
went up on [__] monday or something
there was no problem
and then i went to look at it two days
later when we didn't post on wednesday
and it was 18 and [__] under you know
what i'm like what and then i went back
up on friday to look for something and i
saw that they had put a couple of our
videos
under 18. you got to [__] log in and
[__] you know what i don't even know
what my [__] login is on
on that [__] i can't even re-watch him
or watch him to see what we talked about
because i can't even log in i'm gonna
have to set up a new [__] password
and [__] like that so
my thought is this guys i got a couple
options here
one option is i could just shut down the
youtube believe what i got on youtube
and start transferring the
videos to another platform if they want
to
void this out for the listen it's not
like i'm smoking dope on here anymore
it's not like i'm [__] playing music
on this [__] no more all i'm
doing is it's the language we're not
doing anything and we're not we're not
even talking about the [__] we were
talking about before you know it's been
very calm here i mean like i was telling
somebody a day that the reason why i'm
so upset about them
you know [__] whatever on youtube
well listen i knew the day was gonna
come
i knew that
they didn't like when i smoked on the
videos
i knew that i was getting a little slack
i was getting flagged
for every five times i smoked weed on
here i would get flagged
one out of five times
but guess what there was a time when i
never got flagged at all
so like mike and i were discussing you
don't know what you're gonna say
or what you're gonna do to get flagged
there's some podcasts that i go [__]
raw on i'd do everything but take my
nutsack out on those [__] my
mind took my nutsack out through the
[__] comedy store wanted some
tick-tock dropped it right there
they stop the feed and you know
when you like for a guy like me man
it hurts my feelings a little bit and it
[__]
knocks the wind out of my sails because
i still remember that day
it was you know a month or two after the
pandemic it was like march 5th or
something like that oh no no no no it
was like april when we did that benefit
and
you know we hadn't seen each other
people were [__] freaking out
people were having a hard time you
couldn't touch your mail and [__] like
that
so we decided to do this benefit for the
comedy store
now luka
if you have anything to do with the
comedy store
you know i'm buckwild
i mean ever since i had my daughter and
i got married i got a little older let's
be honest with each other ever since my
i started seeing gray hair on my balls i
don't want to show them to nobody that
that's not good look that's not a good
look my balls used to look good but i
was in my late 30s there was no wide you
know now my hair and my dick
looks like those concerts any any
whatever ghost any trunk goes to those
guys on stage they have like that dry
brittle white and black hair that's what
my [__]
nut sack my dick and all those hairs
around there like
manscape i love madscape and i'll tell
you why i love man's game somebody
complained through my mask and i'm like
let me tell you something [__]
you're wrong on that that ceramic blade
that [__] thing
cuts through my white hairs you have no
idea when you're trimming your dick or
your balls or even your hair or your
eyebrows let's work with my eyebrows
here like if i go upstairs and i help my
wife and i go honey help me set this up
so i could do my eyebrow
dog i used to cut my eyebrows they were
like butter
they were like butter for years
that's it a couple hairs fall down you
brush it off your thing now it's like
this is this is every time that [__]
ceramic blade touches a white hair you
[__] feel it you'll feel like a
little kid though the black hairs are
nothing you know why because there's
nothing left in them
they're like ghosts my black hair is
like grayish they're like [__] ghosts
there's nothing left them they just blow
apart
there's nothing my the black all the
nutrients went into the [__] white
hairs or i think so because my [__]
white hairs you can't cut them you need
like a [__] razor blade i got to get
one of those [__] you know those
rakes and knives and [__] so if you see
my eyebrows uh if my eyebrows are bushy
don't say joey [__] cut your eyebrows
just go jesus christ that [__]
is looking he's in the process of
finding a sharper blade because that's
what it feels like half the time i use
my manscape blade it's so [__] good i
use my manscape blade on my [__]
eyebrows i don't give a [__] anymore
i've had dick on my eye before as a
matter of fact my jaw has been bothering
me the last two days this one in my
previous life i must have been a
[__] i swear to god i can't even
chew gum the last two [__] days it
hurts up here like my wife said i got
lockjaw
so she was sticking her finger in my
mouth and massaging my chest i'm like
forget it i'll live with the [__]
lockjaw enough with the finger like she
was trying to stick her finger deep in
here she had the glove on and no stop
stop we'll do it later i'll do the
podcast and i'll [__] live but it's
monday you bad [__] i'm excited
i'm feeling a lot better i'm looking a
lot better i don't know what my future
holds i just know i'm being a [__]
dad you know and that's what i'm telling
you guys i don't have the life i had
anymore so i'm not going to talk about
the craziness
that i used to talk about because it's
not crazy no more the craziest thing i
do is maybe go to anthony's and get a
pizza with my friend and this
five-year-old kid that's what i did
saturday night instead of going to
dinner with my brother i couldn't
i love my brother but he starts boozing
guys i gotta be honest with you
i can't take boozes anymore i'm sorry if
you're a boozer please don't take it
wrong you know i love you [__]
i'm a disgusting wheathead and i used to
smoke coke and all that [__]
like a coke right now
like if you brought me like a coked out
chick i couldn't listen to her talk like
two coked out people i couldn't do it as
a matter of fact even when i was doing
coke
the last three years i didn't hang out
with coked out people because i couldn't
take their [__] chitter chatter
so drunk people
it's like i i just can't do it no more
you guys i remember i grew up in a
[__] bar
and then i did comedy for [__] you
know however long i did it and every
night you know when you go up for the
first show you're talking to people who
are sober the second show some people
are [__] lit
and i would try my hardest because i'm a
good listener sometimes
but when you're drinking i have no
[__] idea
what people are talking about you know
so it's just weird how
i'm old you know i could talk about
my health i could talk about how what
i'm doing to raise a child
you know i would love to sit here with
you guys and be able every day to just
talk here about the [__] i'm doing how
i'm treating my daughter differently i'm
trying to
raise my daughter differently number one
you guys don't give a frenchman's [__]
which i wouldn't either half years don't
got [__] kids and the other thing
that bothers me about me talking about
my daughter and how we're raising her is
joey
you failed as a [__] father
now you're trying to play [__] cat
like i hate that [__] when i go to like
these uh sporting events
and i see these dads overcompensating
with that kid listen your kid
he's in no danger of doing [__]
stop stop trying to [__] make him a
football player look at him look at him
look at the way he jumps up and down
this kid you're gonna have to have a
talk with him eventually take him to
newark drop them off on the corner let
them get beat up once or twice
i never try to overcompensate with
anybody like that like
if you're not into it i'm not [__]
into it i don't even know what the [__]
we're talking about mike this reef is
getting [__] tremendous last week i
got a new little batch
of uh my my friend called me from
ice cream shop and he goes hey man
are you out of wheat like all i have is
some of the packages left from the
[__] uh coco weed
he goes i'm on one of my friends
atlantic city
and he's hanging out he's got a batch of
the new coco it's not a lot but he wants
to meet you and he wants to drop it off
oh this guy he told me the guy's name i
go yeah come to swing by and the guy hit
me up and he goes hey i'll be there like
at 8 18.
at night which is bad because my
daughter's here i couldn't get high with
the guy he's a good dude but he gave me
a couple [__] buds with a new batch
of the coco holy [__]
holy [__] and i thought that you know i
wasn't gonna get high
i'm one of those idiots that i'm like
i'm not gonna get high in this new
[__] batch because i've been smoking
the old batch i smoked the hell out of
that old batch and even towards the end
i was getting pretty [__] stoned
this new batch i got the new bats i got
the ice cream shop i think i should be
getting some in bags
in the next couple weeks like all
dolled up they just gave me some raw
holy [__] i think i gave some to mike i
gave you one of those buds one of those
brownie buns it's a little browner
and when you put it in the [__]
grinder and it hits the bottom it comes
up like bluish
it's the first time i've seen keith
that's [__] blue it gives it an all
[__] kilter blue
so it's not bad not bad to smoke so i've
been smoking that again
i'm not eating edibles i tell you what i
have been eating lately just to let you
guys know
a lot of you guys referred this [__] to
me for a long time
i had no idea what you were talking
about
you know once i moved to jersey
i lost
that education part of the thc every
time you go to a weed store they got
something else and the people explain it
to you and they're very cordial about it
but i had no idea what the [__] you
people were talking about with delta
nines i had no idea delta nine delta
eight and then our company is putting
out an edible a star of debt
and one of them is gonna be delta eight
so when he sent me the samples
i'll tell you what man i ate a couple of
them and they did the trick and i was
pretty you know but there was also 100
milligrams
of you know civilian dust in there so i
was you know i was like this is pretty
[__] good i went to sleep and it gave
me a little bit of hunger but
i got my hands on some [__] 25
milligram
delta eight edibles
and
i usually give them away and
what's 25 milligrams gonna do to uncle
joey i'm gonna have to eat a whole jar
this the whole jar was 750mg
and i thought about it
you know i was there for a minute i was
like i could [__] inhale this
i was like nah i'm just gonna take
like 125 milligrams so the first night i
just ate like it's 25 milligrams each
gummy and i ate one i ate five of them
i ate it in the afternoon guys by eight
o'clock
i was [__] high
i was in shock i was surprisingly high
i'm like this is not bad
but it wore off like by 11. i'm not a
little off like by 10 10 10 30. it was
like a three hour high
it did the trick you know i'm i'm not in
the mood to be high for 24 [__] hours
i was high for about three hours which
was perfect and i slept like a baby let
me tell you something last night yeah
last night i hit 125 milligrams i did
not feel them at all i can't mo i don't
know because i was i was getting high
for like two hours along with it so i
don't know if i felt it but
i slept eight and a half hours last
night tip
top magoo so
i don't know if you guys eat the delta
whoever was referring it to me thank you
when we release the new stars of death
they will be
[__] uh
one is gonna be straight up the cocoa
weed
and the other one's gonna be delta eight
so we could sell them at health food
stores
and uh because that's where you buy them
around any health food store in jersey
you see delta eight you see a bud so you
don't know what to expect to go in there
i really try to stay out of those
[__] places just uh you know
what you know you guys send me edibles i
got enough
i got the abx's i haven't touched i've
just been living on you know what i gave
the abx a chance and i got to be honest
i'm getting a little higher on the weed
so i think that's true what people say
if you don't eat edibles
you'll get a little bit of [__]
higher
smoking the reef and [__] like that
speaking of which we were talking about
some in the beginning that i want to
touch with these [__] and i
never uh who the [__] knows what it is
guys
no i wasn't talking about reefer i was
talking about oh
i know what it was what i wanted to talk
about last week with you guys about how
i got arrested
january 21st
1983 that was my
first big arrest like it wasn't even big
it was possession of stolen [__] you
know
and i remember that i'm you know like
when i got arrested my friends came down
to bail me out god rest their soul
the peli family came down i was there
with my man stinky one of the guys
rattled on me i forget who the [__] it
was but doesn't make it
doesn't make an ounce of a [__]
different
but i remember that it was all fun and
games at the courtroom and it was all
fun and games on the way home
and it was all fun and games
on the ride to the bar while we were at
the bar you know it was like the scene
from goodfellas you know you got
arrested you broke your cherry and [__]
like that and even when i see that scene
from goodfellas at times
i sit and i go you know what that's a
funny scene for about a minute
like at least it was for me that was a
funny scene
for about a [__] minute like i don't
know
i don't know it's like the scene in
goodfellas when he's going to jail
and he's drinking and his wife
is sitting there lorraine bronco
and she's got them to mink on and she's
got tears in her eyes and as they're
leaving his friends are like hey man
you're uh
you know kiss those hacks for me
or whatever the [__] they're saying ball
bust them as much but they're all really
laughing at him that he's going to
[__] jail
that's how i felt like even being at the
bar and [__] and i'm going home in the
next couple weeks like i lost my job
i went i got arrested i i ended up
owning 200 for my bail which i ended up
getting back you know who the [__] knows
when if i even got it back
but it was just surreal how i felt that
night like i had let my friends down i
had let
my mother down i hadn't let myself down
you know that's
that's horrible my mother was dead like
three years but i know that that was not
her vision for me for me getting [__]
lit you know getting arrested so
and if you know anything about me i
didn't get arrested from
until
i never even considered getting arrested
i mean don't get me wrong the cops said
talk to me whatever you know i was
involved in different [__] in san
francisco in 85 like the y we were
talking about this last week where i was
slinging on the street but i wasn't
getting arrested in san francisco they
would talk to me i don't know what we
would say and then they would disappear
when i was in uh jersey after that i
think i had like four or five months in
jersey and i went to aspen for a year
and then i came back there was i never
got arrested again i thought about that
how it lasted like that arrest had
really
slowed me down a little bit it made me
rearrange
my goals like it was this time of the
year and i remember going like i didn't
know anything about goals
i didn't know anything about
journaling i knew nothing
but i knew that i had some type of
notebook
at the time like just you know where you
wrote phone numbers and
and i remember having
the one dream that i didn't want to
[__] go to jail
but i knew that i had no choice to weigh
between the drugs the reefer
you know stupidity eventually i would
end up there
but i stayed out of [__] jail
for four years in that meantime
i took
six
18 [__] credits from college
i had also
maybe three or f or six credits from
glassboro that i never even transferred
but even though i was [__] up and i
was living in this [__] uh
crazy world i wasn't getting that arrest
saved me for years when i got arrested
the next time
what happened what the [__] happened the
next time i got arrested
he was in boulder
first arrest i took in boulder
was not for anything bad
oh [__]
i got a speeding ticket for driving with
uh like you know you usually go to ocala
and it says we're dropping prices or
sale
you can't drive on the streets anywhere
i think with one of that that [__] on
your window that says like you know yeah
the writing on your window
i went through it
it was a 35 mile an hour but it was
three o'clock in the afternoon
and they switched it to 20 and i didn't
see the light blinking so i was in
reality i was still doing 32
but the cop pulled me over to give me a
ticket and found out i had a warrant
from the [__] windshield writing
there we go you know you know uncle
joey's got an answer for everything
so when they pull me over
the guy goes listen i'm not going to
give you a ticket for the speeding
because obviously you didn't see the
yellow light there was snow something
was going on he goes but i got no choice
with this warrant
i got to bring you in with this war and
i remember i go you know what what's
today's date it was like
april
something of 87 i remember looking at
the cop he was a blonde head cop not a
bad looking guy not a bad guy i still
remember it was
it was an enjoyable arrest as they say
because sometimes i always had enjoyable
arrests we cracked a few jokes blah blah
blah
and he goes i gotta take you down to
your station i'll leave your car here
but since i was nice he called the
dealer
he had like the he radioed into boulder
and they called the dealer he goes you
know uh joey had a little problem no
nothing serious he just had an
outstanding warrant we're gonna go clear
it up it was like 500 to get out of jail
it was nothing
but i remember right in there i said he
goes
when was the last time you were arrested
and i go four [__] and a half years
ago
and i go not too bad and i go that was
my first arrest so he goes ah you're not
gonna have no problems you'll be out of
here now until we got back to boulder
county gentlemen he goes hey man i gotta
search you
and i'm like [__]
i got weed in my sock he's gonna take
off my sock i was
like was 26 years old you didn't want to
smell my feet back then they were
[__] disgusting i was a real [__]
athlete i i didn't have the
the infected toenail the
the [__] uh whatever the fungi
toenail back then so it didn't have that
taste of romano cheese on my feet it was
a different more robust cheese i had
when i was younger it was across through
like [__] muffaletta and which is
really a sandwich joey what the [__] are
you talking about it was like some type
of greek cheese and [__]
foot odor
i didn't think he wanted to smell my
feet i think so i never forget i'm
against the wall he's searching my god
you're clean and he goes do me a favor
take off your sneakers oh my god damn
he's gonna smell my feet i took my shoes
off he goes gotta take off your socks
and when i took off my socks i thought
that the weed
would stick in the sock and i was just
gonna pull it off but he turned the sock
around and a bag of weed fell and he
goes uh what's this
sensamiya season is back and i'm like oh
this guy's being a [__] dick
so i thought he was gonna charge me then
he came back to the sound he goes listen
i'm just gonna get you out of here on
the uh
failure to whatever warrant and
we're gonna make believe like i never
saw the weed and i'm like okay
and i saw him put in this pocket that
[__] smoked my [__]
green sense of meowy that i just picked
up from vince and i bailed out but i
remember that i was very proud of myself
for having like that little [__] four
year gap little did i know i was six
months away from going down the whole
the rabbit hole of my [__] life but
listen i looked at it when you look at
all that [__] now man
i'm happy it [__] went down i'm happy
that i got all that [__] out of the way
guys i haven't had police contact in a
long time i mean there was a cop in
front of my house there that was talking
to him and his kid we were talking about
[__] yeah i talked to [__] cops
there's another guy i go see over at the
pizza place and we meet once every two
weeks whenever he's got time my office
to kelly local guy just gave me some
patches from my other geeky brother i
got an ex-cop brother that [__] wants
patches i love him to death and he
always says to me if you get me cop
patches so he gave me a couple north
bergen patches and then when i meet cops
i go hey do you have any extra
patches i can i got to trade them for
you my geeky brother and they're like we
got a lot of friends who collect patches
and [__] like that so
that's the only contact i have but i
mean even in l.a all those 23 years
i never i [__]
i don't know after i left seattle uh
i think the police got i listened i got
arrested so many times in [__]
seattle
that that was enough to [__] san
gennaro's
20 20 [__] nine so
the last i don't know it was 23 years in
l.a i had nothing i had one [__]
ticket
for being at a light and looking at my
phone to see what direction i was going
to take beside that it's just so weird
how i look back at my life and i'm like
there was a time when i was always in a
[__]
having contact police problems this
probation office is going to meet with a
judge and it's like that's now i had a
cousin who called me
about a year ago
to tell me that a
guy that trains with him a judge wanted
to take me out to lunch i'm like i
haven't been out to dinner with a judge
or anything i never went to dinner with
a judge to be honest with you guys but
it would have been a first for me but
that's the first time i would have had a
contact i talked to a lot of cops today
as friends
i support cops you know how i feel about
the blue
i feel bad for all the officers we lost
over the weekend in new york
there's about to be a [__] war over
there i mean they shot four cops
in four [__] days one is in the
hospital
clinging on to life you know i don't
know what's going on but i do know
the world is in a weird place right now
uh and all we could do is heal it on our
own with laughter
listen to podcasts smoking some reefer
and trying the best that you [__] can
guys
be careful you know i love you
[__] with all my heart i'm
sorry about last week we had a cold
video situation but guess what
[__] we're back we're healthier
than ever the multivitamin is back on
i'm [__] the dick is in good shape
on it is doing the honor six challenge
you could win up to six thousand dollars
i don't know if you guys are into that
uh today's podcast was brought to you by
honored honored [__] uh black label
alpha brain the best
but they're doing this challenge six
it's you could register till
january 30th that's next monday you
could register it's a kettlebell
[__] uh bat
you know
mace and body weight workout that you do
listen honor is on top of it i'm really
happy to be a part of this
i might do the challenge i don't have uh
any mace but i have club bats and
kettlebells and i got a lot of body
weight so i'm not thinking about doing
the challenge i don't know if i'll
qualify for the six g's but i'll [__]
try it
go to honda.com right now
and see how you can join up and be a
part of the challenge and take the
classes at your house and beside that i
love you [__]
have a great week and we'll be back
wednesday morning tip top [__]
magoo i love your [__] and now
for a word for my [__] sponsor
jack all right i want to thank you guys
i'm sorry i've been out of the loop but
we're back we're pushing and listen
we're going to get the party started in
2022 with betterhelp.com i love them the
joint is sponsored by better help online
therapy and i love listen
you guys know me from the church and
before i was not a very therapeutic type
of dude i spoke to somebody early on i
didn't like what was going on but i had
to give it a shot again i was losing my
mind i didn't know what it was
and better help online therapy was there
for me i spoke to a woman called dana
and we broke down anxiety in every form
we could and here i am today feeling tip
top magoo it's like going to a gym or a
dentist you should be caring for your
mental health better help is customized
online therapy that offers video chat
and phone
with sessions with your therapist if you
don't have to see anybody on camera you
don't want to it's fine you can just
talk to her on the phone or chat with
her it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and guess what i'm
going to get you in there with a
therapist as soon as possible so give it
a shot go to
betterhelp.onlinetherapy betterhelp.com
diaz that's betterhelp.com
diaz what better help is going to do is
give you 10 off your first month and
that's going to be great for you and a
better help i want you to listen to that
new podcast getting better on apple
spotify and everywhere else you get your
podcast but listen don't pass up on this
you might be slipping you might be
feeling a little weird
betterhelp.com can help
slash diaz and from the heart of jersey
the joint is brought to you by
draftkings [__] making money
unbelievable four teams remain in the
nfl and they're all going to play next
weekend in the conference championships
you could be in on this with draftkings
the official sports betting partner the
nfl you're counting down to super bowl
new customers i'm gonna give you 56 to
one odds that means if you better thin
to get in you win 280 and free bets are
you kidding me or what oh you're not a
new customer draftkings has your back
with same game parlays combined multiple
bets from same game for bigger payout
the more legs you add the more money you
could win how you like that from your
uncle joey listen they got prop bets
they got a casino it's tremendous
draftkings are safe secure and reliable
and you can deposit withdraw your cash
whenever you want download the draftking
sportsbook app use promo code joey you
got to be 21 older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania colorado tennessee new
customers only minimum five hour deposit
with a dollar wager one per customer
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
slash sportsbook for details if you got
a gaming problem call one eight hundred
gambler but if not it's time to download
the draftking sportsbook app and let's
get this party started and last but not
least it's liquid iv let me explain
something to you they've been sponsoring
me i tasted the lemon lime i wasn't
crazy about it i'm not gonna lie to you
but listen when i got the coven
i tried the grape liquid iv and it was
tremendous listen
i drink it at night i make a container a
16 ounce you put a package in it and i
put it up by my sleep apnea machine at
night when i get up in the middle of
night i'm thirsty i'm i'm dying to
thirst i take a little sip of my liquid
iv and i wake up
feeling a lot better than what i used to
wake up one stick of liquid iv and 16
ounces of water hydrates you fast
faster than water alone it's made with
premium ingredients
vegan non-gmo and free of gluten dairy
and soy and their they're supporting
front line workers to stay healthy
they've donated over 19 million services
servings to hospitals ems food banks
veterans and active military liquid iv
is the best you understand me grab
liquid iv in bulk nationwide at costco
i'm going to give you 25 off when you go
to liquidive.com
use promo code joey at check out i want
to thank liquid iv i want to thank
draftkings
and i want to thanks better help for
having our back this week and i think i
want to thank you guys
for always being a part of the show i
want to thank it for bringing you the
podcast today i love you guys i'll see
you wednesday
tip top magoo stay black guys
you